buenas tardes buenos días soy carlos
hernández y el día de hoy yo hablarte
son las tres reglas de éxito para tener
para poder aplicar en cualquier ámbito
de tu vida
bueno
a lo largo de la prepa participe en
actividades proyectos y eventos que me
permitieron recordar todas las emociones
en menos de minuto ese miedo por
intentar algo nuevo por no saber qué
pasará pero aún más por quedarme con la
duda esa alegría que no solo que más a
llorar no por el resultado sino por el
esfuerzo esta frustración estar dando
todo de mí y aún no sentirme orgullosa
por esa satisfacción de que las cosas no
sólo salieron como creía sino mucho
mejor les ha pasado
pero bueno antes que nada tenemos que
dejar en claro que no se puede triunfar
todo el tiempo como alguna vez dijo dels
en washington que absolutamente no puedo
retroceder quiero que era hacia adelante
imagino que de alguna manera voy a ver
con lo que va a voltear mi cabeza porque
para empezar a tener éxito tenemos que
aceptar que falladas una y otra vez y
entenderás de que el éxito no es la meta
sino todo un proceso de intentos
fallidos
y es aquí cuando entra la primera regla
tener pasión por lo que haces es
fundamental que sin importar tu proyecto
debe tenerle pasión sí pero ni siquiera
como motivación pero esto es seguridad
algo tan nato que tu cuerpo te obligará
a seguir adelante tanto así que no te
vas a ir a la cama sin haber hecho un
avance y te llenará tanto de energía que
te desoladas a las 2 de la mañana para
despertarlo a las 5 y seguir trabajando
porque no importa si estás física y
emocionalmente cansado
intentando
por el simple hecho de que sabes que te
debes esta oportunidad
y bueno está internada sus 26 años
y en esta niña rara bueno dato curioso
entre los usuarios del kinder y era una
niña esa es la semilla relativa su
botiquín a la escuela cuando circulaba a
todos y compraba dulces en forma de
pastillas para recetar los con horas
para eso es claro
a regar los árboles de mi casa cerca
porque si van a morir
siempre y por el bien común y por el
medioambiente
desde entonces sabía que quería ser ese
antes y después en lo que más importa
las personas
pero bueno aunque las mejores
intenciones eso es una de la diferencia
porque tenía que dejar saber cuál es mi
meta cuál es tu visión qué quieres
cuando lo quieres porque para que solo
así sabrás a dónde quieres llegar
desde entonces sabía que quería ser
médico hasta hace ocho meses gracias a
los tópicos las materias entendí que eso
no era lo mío entré en crisis a meses
entré a la universidad
no podía aceptar que estaba deprimida en
verdad entre una depresión fatal porque
como siempre hay problemas familiares de
relación amistades en fin
mi primera reacción fue como hoy no pasó
como yo quería pero mañana con todos y
si mañana con todo y el otro día si este
una materia reprobada no pasa nada este
mañana 120 por ciento nos en 120 por
ciento y así durante dos meses
no podía aceptar que estaba mal hasta
que empezó a afectar las cosas como mi
revés mis amistades mis materias
hasta ese momento recurrí que nuestro
paso buscando ese apoyo ese abrazo de
apoyo incondicional y resulta todo lo
contrario disculpas no podían aceptar
que su hija se estaba derrumbando a tal
punto que íbamos a creía que iba a
terminar la preparatoria
y mi papá enojado obviamente me dijo
cómo retomar esas actitudes infantiles a
estas alturas
uno nunca decide esto
pero bueno encontre tuve que recurrir
estas preguntas que si no son fáciles de
responder pero tienen una idea clara
donde quiere llegar
solo así entendí que puede llegar a mi
meta desde otro objetivo de otro medio
la nanomedicina atacar aquellas
necesidades que aún no han sido
atendidas
pero bueno aún con mi plan de acción
y todo el completito imitación que tenía
hacia esto pues eso más a la diferencia
porque todo recae en el compromiso dejar
las cosas que te gustan por dedicarle
tiempo a tus sueños cuesta pero vale la
pena
se dice que el 99.9 por ciento se trata
de intensidad con la que luchas y sobre
el punto 1 por ciento en los mecanismos
que usas porque tal vez la opción a no
funcionó y tampoco la vez pero que haga
un millón de opciones para llegar a tu
meta
el pasado de enero mientras emitía un
coaching dato curioso número 2 entré en
depresión después del coaching me parece
lógico pero bueno
y en el tema de las fases teníamos que
hacer una donación
y por cuestiones de la escuela de la
donación por el equipo seguir viniendo
boletos chocolates decir compartir la
información entre cosas que la verdad
médica va mucho tiempo
francamente yo no me sentía parte del
proceso porque ni siquiera sabía que me
estaba ayudando
y fue hasta que me puso a investigar
quiénes quienes eran estas personas a
las que estamos apoyando y son la
fundación piel de piel de mariposa
corazón de acero donde vengan brindan
apoyo para las personas que padecen de
termólisis ampollas o piel de mariposa
estas personas viven de esta enfermedad
las cuales generan heridas internas y
externas
no pueden digerir comida no pueden con
el mínimo roce se les prende la piel ni
siquiera pueden recibir un abrazo porque
de lo contrario se lastimaría a caso eso
es vivir
y que después de todo no haya cura
tuve tanto empatía que no puede dejar
las cosas así en algún momento las cosas
que pagamos se iban a acabar
quise tomar acción
pero es
tenía mil cosas más que hacer como
siempre hay que priorizar porque tenía
que mantener mi proyecto en promedio
mire acá mis amistades mis actividades
tiene que improvisar pero entendí que
que todo lo que hacía necesario era 100%
yo era carla hago lo que hago lo que me
apasiona y lo demás fluye naturalmente
era un ganar-ganar
entonces si quería hacer esto quería
apoyar a esta asociación tenía que hacer
ese extra que no había hecho antes en
algo que no me da un beneficio o eso
creía
entonces durante el semestre empecé a
asesorar con procesos con profesores y
como siempre hay quien te dice sabes que
es absurdo dedícate otras cosas sus
materias están reprobando entonces igual
seguir
ya sabía de todo un poco pero no hacía
nada
no tengo tiempo es que los proyectos
tuve que dedicar ese tiempo esas horas
muertas de sueño para llegar a mi
objetivo y solo así llegué a mi primer
prototipo un segundo hasta un cuarto
actualmente forma parte de la segunda
generación directa emprendedor y estamos
viendo la realidad del proyecto para
mejorarla y de sacar a la venta lo antes
posible
esta es la enfermedad
y bueno hace dos meses fui a ver a nadie
es paciente de esta enfermedad y también
coordinadora de la asociación yo la
estoy un área mujer
hablamos de cómo se sentía de las
posibles mejoras de la crema y dos meses
dos semanas después recibo este mensaje
agradecemos la presencia de carla
patricia hernández y ingeniera química
y bueno gracias por ayudarnos a mejorar
la calidad de vida de estas personas no
parecen epidermólisis ampollar
y si esto parece entonces ni siquiera
tenía la certificación mein
certificación de certificado de
preparatoria ni siquiera sabía si estará
la carga correcta
porque eso es lo que pasa porque antes
de que te des tu primer paso ya hay
gente apoyándote yo creo en ti y eso era
lo que necesitaba para dar ese impulso
este es el equipo que de 400 personas
ganamos 25
pasión visión compromiso pasión visión
compromiso pasión visión compromiso
tiene que ser nuestra nueva filosofía de
vida y dice que la cosa puede aplicar en
cualquier ámbito de tu vida se abre
calcar que nunca se ha sabido de alguien
que ha tenido éxito siguiendo los pasos
de otro exitoso
porque cada quien tiene sus propios
obstáculos físicos económicos
psicológicos que nos permiten
experimentar de diferente manera tener
nuestra propia experiencia
tener una vida extraordinaria
ser auténticos
y ahora que lo saben qué van a hacer con
ella
gracias
[Aplausos]